boarding this london-bound train
36-year-old darren pencil
who just minutes later would be involved
in a deadly confrontation
with a fellow passenger that man i.t
consultant lee pomeroy boarded shortly
after
along with his 14 year old son it's just
after 1 pm
on the 4th of january this year almost
immediately
darren pencil and mr pomeroy were
involved in a heated argument
as the train pulled out of gilford
station
pencil accusing lee pomeroy of blocking
the aisle according to witnesses
there's no sound on these security
camera images but the fact they're
arguing is clear
an old bailly jury watched as pencil
moved off
into a neighboring carriage mr pomeroy
followed
and the pair continued their row
moments later the argument turned
violent in
images shown to the jury but too graphic
to be released publicly
the victim is seen being stabbed 18
times
in just 25 seconds before the accused
left the train at clandon station a
british transport police detective
described it as a quick and frenzied
attack
husband and wife christopher and megan
feiberg
witnessed the escalating dispute and
fled the carriage but not before seeing
the two men grab
each other's collars megan feiberg said
the white man
was pretty angry a video testimony from
the victim's fourteen-year-old son was
played in court
he said his father was tall so could
look pretty menacing
that he heard pencil tell his dad to get
off at the next station
which he perceived as a threat the
defendant's girlfriend chelsea mitchell
is also on trial but denies assisting an
offender
darren pencil admits possessing a knife
but has pleaded not guilty to murdering
lee pomeroy
mark white sky news